[Music]
on today's show we talk about
dating with physical insecurities we
talk to a young woman whose parents are
hoarders and she doesn't know what to do
and we have a heartbreaking call with a
woman who's been in abusive relationship
for 19 years
she's got five kids she doesn't know
what to do next
stay tuned
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john delony show i hope
you're doing well
i hope you are laughing having joy in
your life and if you're not i hope you
got people around you to sit with you
when things are hard
we've got a packed packed lobby out
there
this is unbelievable man and by packed i
mean two
two hope neither of you are in witness
protection and i hope that
both of you are dating each other or are
married to each other
and you haven't told somebody else no
dude i've got a work event so
that could be really awkward for
everybody and lucky for you there's only
like 17 and a half people that watch
youtube so no one would know anyway but
it's good it's good it's good to see
everybody
in the packed audience for the listeners
there's two
there's two and a co-worker walking
through the lobby
two people man when you know you could
really
pack a house when you're john deloney
that's for sure hey guys so i haven't
seen you all in a few
in a while it's good to see everybody i
missed you guys
we've been out running around the
country and it's good to see everyone
you did a great job yes i'm very proud
of you well i think
it makes my heart feel good and while i
was gone james you got a new toy
oh yes i did do you want to talk about
it it's a
i mean this is a mental health call-in
show and you made a terrible purchase so
i think we should talk about it what'd
you get i got
another fender guitar fender jaguar
jaguar what would
what would prompt somebody of sound mind
to think that's the next guitar for me
was your other fenders just not jingly
and tinny and
and yeah this one has something called a
strangle switch which
cuts base out and makes it even more
jingly than the other fenders
i think the world's full of jangle we
got enough jangles in the world
but congratulations i know you're really
happy it's got like 88 switches on it
looks like a home depot man
but good for you thanks zach you look
great in there
happy as always you and your atlanta
braves hat making me sad
but i'm so glad everybody's here if you
want to be on the show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one go to johndaloni.com
show and fill out that form and if you
have emails
um or uh have particular questions go
ahead and send them into the
show link as well and we'll try to
answer them here on the show
so we got a packed house today so let's
go directly to the phones let's go to
vince
in des moines iowa is going to say des
moines yes for a joke
inside joke but i didn't des moines iowa
what's up vince how are you man
hey john thanks for uh this call and you
can say des moines it's absolutely
french for
i don't think it means anything so we're
all good yeah i'm gonna say
i thought it was french for can't
pronounce right
but it's good right but thank you uh
thank you for the 39 people that you do
help on an everyday basis
um i'm one of that 39 so i thought i'd
call and get some advice from you well
man i appreciate you doubled
the true number but i i appreciate that
man and it's early where you are so i
appreciate you getting up early so
what's up brother how can i help man
so my question is is i just recently
turned 50 i've been divorced for about
four years
and i want to start entering into the
dating world my kids are now out of the
house
and i have a condition i have a
condition what's called
benign essential tremor and anxiety
makes it worse i am on medicine that
helps
reduce it but it's still evident and my
fear is
obviously a fear of rejection going out
on a date when you when do you reveal
such a thing hey my profile oh by the
way
i love nice quiet walks along the beach
and i love picturesque sunsets and by
the way i have a trimmer
i mean i don't know how i play it in
because
i'm you know i'm generally you know i'm
in
good shape i'm a nice looking person i
you know
think i have a lot to offer but it does
hold me back because much like your kids
saying to or your child saying why do
you have such a big belly
i've had nieces and nephews saying
uh hey vince why why do your hands shake
you know and so it's
evident to others sometimes i'm not even
aware of it because i'm so used to it
i've had it for so long yeah
but my ex-wife uh weaponized it
against me even thus you know the term x
because and it's made me self-conscious
about it and just wanted some input from
you
man well thanks for sharing that dude um
that was gonna be my first question
when did somebody start beating you up
over this and you answered it there have
you had this your whole life or is it
is it um a recent onset in the last five
six seven eight nine years how long have
you been dealing with this
i've had it um essentially my whole life
my twenties okay
and what was i not it's i mean i'm just
looking at the the name of it benign
essential tremor
what what what causes the onset of this
so it's just it's a neurological misfire
um
so whereas you know everybody has
some level of tremor right so
when you're doing specific actions like
if i'm gonna go hold a glass of wine you
might see my
my wine glass moving a little bit
whereas somebody else's is
steady okay and then it's just there
it's it's
it's not curable um the medicines you
know
help dampen it a bit you know
so your your wife met you and you were
already
shaken right a
tiny amount okay it's gotten a little
bit worse with age
but a tiny amount so what happened
over the arc of your marriage that
suddenly she
she making fun of you about it giving
you a hard time about it saying it's
embarrassing to her like
what was the thing uh all the above
anything and everything of just verbal
combat and that was something to kind of
quote poke at my disability ah
okay so it was just a way that she knew
she could get under your skin
almost like it didn't even bother her
but she knew that it bothered you and
when y'all over in a fight she could get
you completely
yeah okay so what do your kids say what
do you have buddies do they give you a
hard time but still love you
they do okay um they don't give me they
don't give me a hard time they just
accept it you know and every once in a
while when a new person comes into the
circle
they're like hey has he gotten checked
out you know
is it parkinson's you know and things
like that and they're all like no
you know he's had it forever and so i'm
thinking you know
i would like to go back into the dating
world and have
a companion in the future and things
like that absolutely
so here's the thing um i hate it
let me back out so my oldest friend on
planet earth
like our we were zero together right
um is a
paraplegic now after a car wreck and
me and him and his little brother and
another neighbor the four of us have
been buddies for
since i've been on earth right and i've
been stopped we
we have collectively been stopped in a
parking lot by people with good
hearts trying to intervene because we're
all making fun of each other
in poking at each other and really
giving each other a hard time for
anything we could find about each other
right um i had bad acne as a kid oh my
gosh they let me have it
and now we've got a friend in a
wheelchair and we let him have it and
he will humiliate you in a restaurant
i mean it's just back and forth and back
and forth and so
there's part of me that loves having
friends who will call out the obvious
and who i know still love me right who i
know still have my back there's
something
endearing for me about sharing in each
other's
sharing in the in the things that drive
us crazy about ourselves that our
friends love
right and then there's people who man if
somebody else was walking
in a in a parking lot and popped off
about my buddy
i'd probably go to jail right because
you're not going to talk that way about
my friend does that make sense and
where it's the same exact behavior but
there's different context to it
so for you
i want you to turn this thing around man
and just own it
it just is and what i want to tell you
is
you've got the back half of your life
here right where you're
not going to quote unquote build a life
with somebody you're going to have
someone in your life that you're just
going to have
the time of y'all's life you're going to
get old and grumpy together you're going
to laugh
and you're looking for a like a a
companion right uh someone to right play
down the rest of the the tread on your
tires
right and so that's a person that's
gonna be right or die that's gonna laugh
with you and love you
and man if somebody's gonna give you any
grief or
ask anything other than the obvious
questions they're out
right and so this is you and the more
you
are apprehensive about it or weird about
it or
i don't it is just you man it just is
and it's a lovely fun engaging part of
you and so
asking when do you want to bring it up
if you're if i'm you i'd bring it up as
early as possible
and you say hey this is i'd also wait
till i was i don't know that you have to
email somebody or feel self-conscious
you're not setting somebody up to to
um be ashamed or embarrassed does that
make sense
it does this is you right and if you go
out with somebody and they look at you
and say hey why
why tell me about this tremor and you
said yeah i've had this for 20 30 years
and then you're a great guy and you're
fun and
there's some gentle play back and forth
and some fun this and that's and you
make jokes and she makes jokes about
50 different things right then
man i think that's awesome and if
somebody looks at you and says i'm not
going to be with you
this is weird this is gross man just get
up and walk out the door that makes it
life is too short brother you're 50.
and i think i just i do need that
confidence boost
yeah you know hey this is about well
just just whoever would take me you know
is kind of
i know i know hear how you're saying
that whoever will take me man
as though you're a damaged product
you're not
you're not i'm a weird weird human being
my tremors are less obvious than yours
that's the difference
that makes sense yeah i know fair enough
and so dude you're not a defective car
in a in a in a in a like a car lot
hoping that somebody just takes me home
right that's not you
are you a good dad yeah do your kids
love you
what's without question okay are you a
funny guy
like do people like hanging around you
they do
usually inject energy and excitement but
when it gets down
to you know the quietness of
people that don't know it just it just
makes it a little bit hard sometimes
it does it does and i'm i i my hope for
you
is that after this call you hang up and
you go look in the mirror and you say
i'm a good dad i'm a good guy and my
hands shake
ta-dah all right and anybody
is is gonna be fortunate to have you in
their life
they just are you're not broken brother
i appreciate that and you know i do
practice a lot of your
box breathing you know you talk about
and things like that but it
just wanted to hear your perspective of
throwing it out there and
when to introduce it and i appreciate
your input on it because
you're right i've got to work for
embracement
and taking it for what it is because
you're right i'm on the back half and i
want to have
a lot of good times if in all
directness if i'm you i would mention it
on a first date
okay i would sit down with and have
coffee and if it's is it really
obvious when you sit down to have a
drink with somebody
or is it when you get nervous and you
get anxious
it's it's exacerbated by anxiety so
so the first time you meet someone new
yeah okay so it's gonna be a little bit
nervous or
i mean i would just put it out there and
say hey
it's me not you it's kind of you you
know i think you can spin it off and
then you're off to the races right
yeah take it to whatever it's worth all
right yeah nice just
serious yeah and put on when and where
you interject
and because i can't hide it
and hey listen you don't need to hide it
you don't need to hide it
you're vince you're a good dad you've
won life and now you're looking for
someone to yeah rock till the wheels
fall off man
and nothing to hide nothing to
uh be embarrassed about i
mean i'm kind of yeah i mean i've got
some strong opinions on this
um that i'm going to keep to myself
go be fully humans that's it
and how about this people if you're an
idiot and
you don't want to date people that um
you don't want to go out and have a good
time you don't want to build a fun
exciting wildlife with somebody
that has something that is outside the
bell curve of quote unquote normal
right we are all temporarily able-bodied
right we're all
on borrowed time when it comes to how we
just run around the world and so if you
want to be somebody who's like no they
have to fit this profile
you you put your bias out there
you go first you say i do not want to be
with anybody who is missing any fingers
or toes
who may have a tremor may have a weird
loud laugh
i have a loud bursty laugh it's super
annoying i get embarrassed as my wife in
the movies that's why she doesn't like
to go to movies with me because i laugh
so loud
laughing for me is one of my favorite
things in the world whatever your thing
is that you don't want to be around
you put that out there that way people
can see that you're an idiot and
they won't people like vince who are
awesome won't call you how about that
vince you're not you're a good guy man
and i think there's a way to
have some fun with this and to lead with
it
and then get about the more important
business of being known
and discovering who had the courage to
go out with you and they're going to be
lucky to
how about this vince when you get
married holler at us we'll we'll
celebrate for you and we'll we'll have
some fun
at your expense and with you because
that's what we do here all right thank
you so much let's go to lynn
in houston what's up lynn how are we
doing
i'm doing good how are you dr daloni i'm
good how's houston
it's good it's good good hey so what's
going on how can i help
well i just um wanted to call in and
talk to you about something i've been
struggling with um i've never really
talked about this with anyone but
my parents are hoarders um
and you know this past year has really
just taught me
how important family is and the
relationships are
and i am just overall health
and um this has been something i've been
you know struggling with trying to talk
to my parents about
um and i really just want to help them
out and i
don't know how to navigate all the
different ways of going about it you
know
yeah hoarding's really hard right
real hard how long have they been doing
that um
well as i graduated um
i just graduated and i left home about
five years ago and that's where
it got got pretty rough um
it's been like this it's been piling up
for the past probably 10 years
um what was the impetus
was there some some trauma that happened
was there some sort of incidents or
incidents or did somebody pass away what
was the thing that
kind of hit that domino um
that's a good question i've kind of
thought about that a lot um
i mean my parents my parents marriage
isn't the best
um and i think you know a lot of it was
just
you know just kind of turmoil in the
house um
they live pretty separate lives you know
yeah um
so it's not connected so well um
so what do you want to what do you want
to do you want to help them what do you
want to do
well you know i would love to get the
house cleaned out um
i i would love for them to be able to
just sell the house and move out
um where do you want to be where do you
want them to move
um i mean here in houston would be great
for them to move to
um closer to me mean i would love to
help them out
um but you know i
i i guess i need advice on is
like i try to talk to my mom about it i
talk to her the most about stuff i don't
really
i haven't i don't talk to my dad a lot
about this because i know it's a sore
subject
um i talked to her about it probably
about like five months ago
i was really struggling with it because
i
you know i feel bad um
sorry i feel bad like i was in school i
just always felt bad
leaving because i knew like there was no
like i she she sees like me my sister is
like help to her
and i want to be able to help her but
you know i
it's hard for me to to even yeah
so here's the thing number one
hoarding is really a tough tough
challenging thing to to be in a
relationship with someone who's a
hoarder okay
the second thing is you can't solve that
there's
very very little you can do to get that
house cleaned out
and that's really hard and you're
it's like watching somebody drown
slowly and you have your arm out and
they just won't grab it
and their way to deal with the fact that
they're going under
is to get more stuff right to get
another pet and another pet or another
fill in the blank or just to continue to
continue to continue
it is agonizing for people who love
folks who are hoarders
it's hard bigger than that
is what you just brought up which i'm
glad you did which is
you're trying to help and save your mom
and that's not your job and you can't do
it
your mom's a grown-up and she at some
point has to make grown-up relationship
decisions
and you and your sisters can't be her
therapist that you can't be her
spiritual advisor you can't be the
person that makes everything okay for
her
because ultimately what happens is this
is how generational loops
happen right you end up giving up a big
chunk of your life
to make sure that her life is not okay
because it's not gonna be okay because
she won't deal with the hard hard stuff
but it's just enough to keep her her
head above water
and in the process you spend all of your
life underwater
profiter up and then you end up with
your generational traumas that you pass
on to your kids and so on and so forth
and so the the most important thing
somebody can do who's
who's in a loving relationship with a
hoarder
is to set really firm boundaries so that
you can be
as well as humanly possible if you grew
up in this situation my guess is you've
got
some sort of challenges on your own is
that fair
uh definitely yes sir okay okay
and so what i would recommend you do is
really get after those
in a in a direct and this
generational trauma stops with lynn
stops with me and there's a great quote
by terrence
real generational trauma rolls
through families like a forest fire
until one person has the courage to turn
and face it and say no more
and lynn you can be that person the only
shot
you've got to helping mom and dad is by
shining a light directly on yourself
this is what healthy this is what well
looks like this is what boundaries feel
like this is what ownership
looks like this is what good decision
making looks like this is what a healthy
relationship can look like this is what
someone who goes to counseling can look
like
that's the shot you've got but there's
not a piece of advice you're going to be
able to tell your mom that she's going
to go
oh i didn't think of that i'm going to
clean the house that's not going to
happen
that's a fantasy right there's not a
special
taster's choice meal that you and her
going to have where you're gonna finally
she's gonna the music will swell
and she'll look at you and go you're
right i'm gonna go deal with my that's
not gonna happen
and so what the the what you're left
with
is either continue to hang on for for
her for dear life or
to take care of yourself i would
recommend
with all of my heart writing her and
your dad a letter letting them know that
you love them
and letting them know that you really
want them to be well
and whole and you would love to be a
part of
um helping clean their house up if they
ever come to that decision on their own
and then that way you get all that out
you put on paper you send it
they can go back to it over and over and
over again in various stages where
they're
where they're well where they're not
doing well and then you can be about
being well yourself what's one thing
that you know
i've gotta i've gotta deal with just one
what do you mean um do you are you a
person who struggles with anxiety
person who struggles with with boundary
issues with depression
what are you working through right now
um
i mean i've i was diagnosed with bipolar
disorder
so i've been yeah working with through
that anxieties
do you take your medication um i
recently got off of it
um lynn i know
don't i i'm working since i
was like stayed in houston um
i've been working with trying to find a
new psychiatrist here because this one
was back in dallas so okay so listen
today
right today
you can live a remarkable life with
bipolar disorder
if you will partner with professionals
and do what they say
okay living with bipolar is really hard
isn't it
yeah and on some weeks you can do more
than your co-workers can do in a month
and then on some weeks
it feels like there's an elephant on top
of you right
right yeah definitely um
so wait will you commit will you commit
to making a phone call
today lynn
you'll make a phone call today yeah i um
i've been really wanting to get back
into counseling since i graduated i
lost my student counseling so i'm
looking for a therapist right now
actually
excellent excellent excellent so you
just committed in front of
me these two folks out in the lobby
and a whole bunch of other people you're
going to take care of yourself that's
the avenue if there is one to help your
parents
it sounds like there's a whole bunch
underneath
the actual hoarding whole bunch
underneath
bipolar sounds like there's we could you
and i could talk for hours
at the end of the day the meta here is
you've got to develop boundaries you've
got to be well you've got to work on you
and i do think the integris honorable
thing to do is to let your parents know
that you love them you're here to help
at any moment and
let that be that right let that be light
and that's so hard especially when you
love your parents you love them so much
and you want to go fix it and you can't
so hard thank you so much for that call
lynn hey everybody we'll be right back
on the dr john dolone show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just
walking with you through your anxiety
alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free
and it's for everyone you can download
this guided meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's go out to liz in mobile
alabama
hey liz what's going on hey
drilling thanks for thanks for speaking
with me thank you so much for giving me
a shout
everybody doing well um
yeah as best we can best we can uh oh
okay fill me in so what's going on
okay so i um
oh i'm a recently single mother of five
how recently
uh and it's been a couple of weeks um
and we're kind of
you know always between a rock and a
hard place it seems um this is a
long-term uh domestic violence
relationship
oh man um we were
uh never married uh we do have all of
these children in common they're all
ours
okay um but it's come down to an
ultimatum
situation where we've separated and
gotten back together multiple times
before sometimes in the midst of
physical violence sometimes
not but i feel more and more that i'm at
my
breaking point with the psychological
turmoil and also the logistics of now
having to you know provide four or five
young children um after having
for the most part been a stay-at-home
mother for
you know over 15 years so you've been
with the same person for 15 years you
have five kids
been physically abusive this whole time
and
you have had moments where you stood up
tall and walked out and you circled back
and you circled back and you circled
back
and now you're worried about the
psychological impact
what was it about the physical impact
the physical abuse
that was okay for you
not so much that it was okay
i think it certainly came back to a
self-esteem issue
and difficulty in childhood and having
you know really realizing that worth
that i
don't deserve this um and recently kind
of connecting
to a community for
the first time in many years enabled to
maintain friendships
um and being exposed to other women or
other families that are experiencing you
know similar things and i was able to
get angry
yeah for them and then able to realize
well you know what i don't deserve this
either
no you absolutely don't and
your kids can't be around that
right right yeah and i realized
ultimately that becomes the stamp that
becomes the
imprint that becomes the picture of what
a normal relationship is because it's
the only one they know
right right and i realized that more and
more especially with
my older children the
you know the mimicking of behaviors the
learned behaviors and the way that they
interact and
you know it's set off red flag after red
flag in my mind like i know this
yeah i know this and i can't allow this
to perpetuate but on the other hand
being um you know essentially a
dependent for so long
um working out logistically how to care
for a family on my own
that's ultimately what has brought us
back is that i've
exhausted every resource tried to do
everything possible
and so i i want to pause there and i've
i've heard this over and over and it's
probably
one of the most tragic untold stories
um in our culture which is
everyone knows the evils of physical and
psychological abuse
relational relationship abuse we all
know right even the people experiencing
the people who have never
seen it know that's not right
the other side of that is
i've heard over and over
especially by women experience physical
violence
with children who will say yeah but i
got to eat
right yeah and there's nowhere to go and
so there
is this i this this terrifying sense of
being trapped right
yeah it's the lesser of the two evil
situation well
okay are they gonna be happy and safe
and healthy but um
but they may not have a roof over their
heads because
you know what else what else could we do
this is the one thing
the one hold that he may have on us
ultimately is that financial support but
only if you're here with me
right that's right and it becomes the
the demon you know and the demon you
don't know
and i just want to thank you for for
being brave and vulnerable there
i i know that there are so many folks
who will never experience the hell that
you've experienced
but can it's real easy to monday morning
quarterback that if that ever happened
to me i would just yeah you don't know
right because it's terrifying if you're
going to stay at home so how come you
never married this guy
besides the obvious you know it was a
dream of mine for so long
um you know what girl doesn't want that
uh you know that that fairytale wedding
and
to marry the man of your dreams and to
have a healthy happy family with
children and all the things
um so who told you you weren't worth it
who told you you weren't worth that
i don't know that no anyone necessarily
expressed
that or made me feel that way but when
you know in the beginning
it you know it started off as we were
college students and with an unplanned
pregnancy and then it was just kind of
put off and put off and put off he had a
lot of excuses
yeah but somebody showed you somebody
gave you a picture of
a woman's worth at some point
where does that come from
i don't know if it's so much a woman's
worth or my worth specifically but
growing up
i always felt less than
there was something innately wrong with
me
you know my my father worked
you know quite a bit was wonderful
supported the family
but he you know worked the nine to five
and sometimes more and my mother was not
emotionally present
when i started presenting as depressed
as an adolescent it was a problem
and it was something we had to keep
quiet and nobody could know about
it was difficult for me to find support
because of kind of the keeping up with
the jones's
dynamic and our family so your
the way you felt in the struggles that
were going on and
the hell you were living through was
something that
you needed to figure out how to keep a
lid on because we have other stuff to do
yeah and then you end up with
an unplanned pregnancy and the way you
feel about things and the way you want
to do things and the
fears and terror that you experience
that's something you need to put a lid
on
because we got stuff to do right yeah it
was it was very much a frying pan
to fire situation where you know i
finally found somebody that seemed
enamored and infatuated and thought i
was wonderful and i felt special
and loved for maybe the first time
and then it when i realized what i'd
gotten myself into and what was
happening it was
it was too late it was too late but
you had five kids with him
that's a lot
so after child two after child three
tell me what you're thinking as you're
walking this road
this is something very
probably one of the hardest struggles
that i deal with internally because you
know people are cute and they like to
say oh are they all yours
you know you know what causes that don't
you yes
but nobody sees through um i'm sorry
no you're good through the you know all
the facets of an abusive
relationship or a coercive or
manipulative relationship
where
it's difficult to talk about things like
you know i know we're not actually
married but marital rape
or things where you feel like saying no
is not
an option or maybe it will keep the
peace or maybe now he'll be in a better
mood where it's
obligation yeah um i
i didn't have the voice nor the ability
he's much
much stronger than i am um yeah you know
it's
and you know hearing these comments and
to no fault of these people who are
think they're being you know funny or
cute you know yeah we have a television
now yeah i took care of it thank you
yeah they're mine
and they don't know the trauma on the
other side of it right yeah
right yeah yeah and so what was the
final straw that you said enough is
enough is enough
we've always kind of lived in a check to
check situation he's still
he runs his own business um
so we we've never you know we've always
struggled we've always
we owned a home briefly and then moved
and we've rented
for so long and the kids are always
we've moved many times the kids are
always very
unstable they say things like you know
at our next house or this or that or are
we going to move
soon because i really don't want to
leave my friends or this or that
really when i realized how deep um
i have very little control over finances
if any um and when i realized that he
was kind of perpetually making these
excuses keeping us in the situation
we were going without because of
selfishness
things like this and that in combination
with the name calling
the criticizing just the anger and the
yelling
the kids i noticed that they would
disappear go to hide
you know kind of slowly slink away and i
said that we can't do this
yeah i can't um he actually was the one
that gave me an ultimatum you know
unless you get your stuff together and
start taking care of me like
it's your job to do it to make me happy
i'm not moving again with you and i said
okay so this is the first time we've
ever been on the same page
um then that's fine so go ahead and he
he
you know ultimately did
decided he wasn't going to fulfill his
financial obligations as far as basic
living expenses and
and you know let the chips fall where
they may which ended up in us
having to leave our home and so he was
able to take care of his
end and get his own home for the family
um which the family has never lived in
and we
uh stay in a for the last couple weeks
we've been in a pop-up camper
in a friend's backyard and i'm trying to
scramble
and do figure out what i can yeah
but there's always that looming if
things get bad enough we may have to go
back and figure and regroup and i just i
don't want to go there again
yeah so do you have a
any sort of church community friend
community that will give your kids
a house for two months three months or
has there been any sort of
um connection with the women's shelter
there in your local area
that will take everybody in y'all can't
stay in a backyard pop-up camper not
five kids
um i you know i'm well acquainted with
women's shelters in our area i'm
i've been i've stayed there um
once for quite some time a couple of
years ago
and ultimately this is the what's
unfortunate is although they have
as many resources as they do they do
what they can they help so many families
and women i saw so many people come in
and out
the ultimately what they can do
is limit it especially for families of
this size
with no financial savings or no job
prospects
it's just starting everyone
from square one and sometimes it's just
most of the time maybe
all of the time it's just not possible
um that's what i've found so what about
your friends and community
or even if you have to say three of them
go to this house for a while and two
go to this house um you got to get those
those kids under a roof that's that's
where they're safe and i know you know
that i'm not trying to pile on
i'm trying to encourage okay yeah
yeah no i i i you know it breaks my
heart to think about
um
having to separate them uh that's i know
definitely probably one of my other
hang-ups is
you know so so you know why didn't
think of it this way what you are
and it makes so much sense and i can't
think of any more
pure heart here so i'm i'm walking
alongside you okay
this isn't a finger wagging thing this
is just me
is you're trying the best you can
to keep the picture of a family that you
have had in your head since you were a
little bitty kid
intact
and that is on fire right
and so yeah absolutely there comes
moments of i like walking hand in hand
with
my two kids and my wife but if the house
is on fire
everybody's got to get out in the yard
and i've got to run into the house and
get as much stuff out into the front
yard as possible
right because it's an emergency and of
course
nobody's going to separate your family
long term no chance no how no way
not under liz's watch right that's not
the kind of mama you're going to be
right
right yeah but in an effort to
hold this picture together so tightly
because there's so little in your world
you can
control right because you've got a an
abusive
evil person who has created a universe
for you where you've got nothing
right and so in an effort to control you
can control you hold on to this picture
really tight and suddenly you find
yourself in a camper in a backyard
with five little kids trying to finish
out a school year on the back end of a
pandemic and
it's it's it's that that picture is
cracking and cracking and you're just
gonna hold tighter and tighter and
tighter
right so there comes moments when
it's okay to exhale and say
billy and tommy you all are going to go
stay with the smiths and i'm going to
see you every single day
and the other three are going to go stay
with so and so
and i'm going to stay with you all too
and because things are on fire
and i'm gonna have to work like crazy
to find me a job of some sort
you are gonna have to start from square
one and this is hard
and it's awful and it's wrong
and it's easy for me to say you need to
get the authorities involved
that's my recommendation but i also know
that makes you even less safe
right and when somebody's i mean it is
when somebody's got their own go ahead
i'm sorry it is it is just so difficult
because we have been here before where
you know through we do have a church
community it is you know a small
congregation
um but they were able to bless us
several years ago
and we were able to find our own home
and we did well
well not well we got by for several
months almost a year
and i found then that even
working full-time and then some and
taking
advantage of subsidized child care for
my youngest ones and
you know public school for the rest and
day care i
worked as much as i possibly could had a
couple
of side hustles even and even so at the
end of the month
there were more you know there was
at the end of the money we still had
bills yeah you know i was able i was
taking a little bit from savings every
month and a little bit more and a little
bit more till eventually it was just
gone
yeah and he was able to come in like
save the day the savior that is his
personality type
you know i have this house then we can
be a family
yeah and i felt like i did not have
another option have you sat down
hopefully now post pandemic when housing
prices are through the roof almost
doubled what they were a year ago in
this area
yeah um it seems just hopeless like i am
crazy to be thinking that i can do
this you're not you're not
um have you sat down with the police and
an attorney
to get child support so that that money
that he needs to be paying comes without
him
i have it's very it's very convoluted
and when i say i've exhausted every
resource i'm not being flippant i really
mean over the past several years
um you know like i said when you own a
business
a lot of unfortunately a lot of it is
off the books
a lot exactly cash taxes are
not an accurate representation by a long
shot of income
child support has been a joke
um and that's that those are the things
that
you have to have to lean on oh yeah
yeah i understand if it was accurate i
feel like we could maybe
just slide under just make it but it's
just
um i'm not even sure how to go about
it's it's a matter of for example for
five kids you know a monthly payment of
four hundred dollars is
wonderful yeah that's where we're at
exactly
that's where getting with an attorney
who will do a forensic account
accounting of his resources right
that's where you may consider taking all
five kids and moving in
with a sister who's in colorado or
somewhere across the country
that's where you pick up and you start
looking at where are places where
women in your situation are taken care
of better than they are in your local
community
and what i'm talking about stepping out
and looking and saying i've got to
rebuild this thing from the floor
up and you got to change the oil on this
car while it's moving right
right and so here's what i want you to
do i want you to begin to think of this
as a two to three to five year
project not a two-month project and i
know that sounds so flippant it feels so
overwhelming
that's where you can sit down and
especially get somebody to walk
alongside you
who will help you build out here's what
a budget's gonna look like
hey attorney i need you to know that
this is how my husband does business
he runs stuff under the table it's not
cash i can point you to some of the
people who pay him
on how he's actually living you can go
do a forensic account so what they'll do
is they'll look at the things he
actually buys
the money that flows through not just
the taxable income
and they'll come up with a full picture
of what he makes
and that's how you can get in and find
out or get
the child support up to where it needs
to be and then what most
scumbags in that situation do is they'll
literally take less
clients so they'll have to pay less
right
and so it's a game of cat and mouse the
big thing here
is do you go back to school do you sit
down with your church and say over the
next nine months the next
year here's where i'm gonna be can y'all
help me out
is there a couple of folks who at your
local church or your local group or
wherever your mom lives or wherever your
sister lives
and i'm making people up here right that
would be willing to help out with
babysitting in exchange for
fill in the blank and so you're talking
about a
long term play and there is
unfortunately no um
there's no happy ending of this tomorrow
or a month from now or three months from
now
what you do know is what happens when
you go back
right right and
i mean on the one on the one side i
completely understand that there's no
quick fix it's gonna be
a lifelong honestly a lifelong healing
for everybody it's going to be a
constant process but we're going to move
towards getting better
and i have on the other hand been
in the alternative for over a decade so
i know
yeah exactly i know it's i know it's
time
and it's a process right um it's
i think the one thing that holds me back
is you know
on the one hand the crippling anxiety um
and it's you know the overwhelming
these the sheer overwhelmingness of it
of all of the things not only figuring
out
the living situation the money the guilt
over asking
for so many things from so many people i
need help here and help there
um but also managing the needs of you
know
children that aren't school age yet the
ones that are
that want to do you know why can't i do
sports why can't i go to a friend's
house
i need help with my homework but i you
know the fear of not being there because
i'm gonna have to work so hard
yeah um in addition you know to
being mother to all of them um so listen
and not have me
resent me and say well you know things
are better with dad
and that's where i want you to always be
leaning towards a long game you're
playing here
okay here's why there will come a moment
when your kids will turn back and you
will become
the maternal figure that changed the
trajectory of this family
you and there will come a season when
your kids will turn
and look at the sacrifices you made
and the unbearably
guilt-ridden conversations you had to
have or that you asked somebody to have
on your behalf
that allowed them to be where they are
now
and that's why i need you
the only thing i'm going to ask of you
number one is don't go back
ask furiously do what you've got to do
to ask furiously for help reach out to
resources
just start banging a gong on the street
okay
and i want you to call your church's
bluff and if they say who they say they
are
then they should rally around you it
helps for you to have some very clear
needs
one of those needs for instance is i
need somebody to go ask the local little
league
if they have a scholarship program for
kids who's
and i guarantee you somebody in your
church who doesn't have a lot of money
but
loves a good deal will get on the phone
and make sure that your kids are playing
little league this summer
and somebody who needs some
i will be the best um i will be the
i'll make cookies i will do whatever i
don't have money to pay
kids for babysitting but i will write
the best
um letters of recommendation i will fill
in the blank
because you've got so much value to
offer you've been what you've been
navigating
you would be a you would be a
thunderdome lawyer
right you would be an incredible navy
seal i hung out with jocko this past
week
you could stand next to him okay
you are um a powerful strong
woman the person who's got to believe
that is you
and i want the people and you've got to
have some space to breathe so you can
even see it
right and so here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to do a couple things for you
first thing is um for the listeners who
don't know i work here at ramsey
solutions i'm going to give you a year
of ramsay plus here's what that here's
here's why that's important people are
going to ask like that's got all the
financial peace university
it's a budgeting thing and i know you're
saying i don't have any money to even
budget
i get that when things feel
super overwhelming it feels like
everything's raining and i can't figure
out what
what thing to do next
to put where that's exactly right and
the roof is caving in oh and the
in the in the front door is on fire
right what this does is it breaks down
chaos into a step by step by step
plan bus particularly with your money
but more importantly than that
it gives you a plan for intentionality
for your whole life
so at the same time you're playing a
five year game you're also playing a
minute by minute game
and liz it's exhausting and so i want
you to
reach out to folks in your church and
say
i need a day i need two hours a week
where i can just breathe
i need fill in the blank i need to fill
up like this will help you break down
your needs
step by step by step i'm going to send
you a copy of my book redefining anxiety
yeah for all this we're going to send it
to you for free and i want you to go
back to it and go back to it here's the
thing
you're crippling anxiety it means your
brain is working great
it means everything is firing on all
cylinders your body's been telling you
for years you're not safe
and you know this right yeah yeah where
it gets hard is you haven't valued
yourself
and now suddenly you're starting to
realize my kids aren't safe and you
value them
right and that makes all of my world
much exactly exactly and so you've got
some really hard choices on the horizon
what i want to tell you is if your kids
are playing a little league
that somebody else helped you get for
free while you're out going back to
school or you're out working and then
going back to school
and somebody else is helping tuck your
kids in at night and they are just a
saint and you're thinking i can never
pay you i can never repay you i can
never repay you
or there's two grandmothers at your
church who are rotating or two granddads
who are rotating
helping out because it's they've set
themselves up in their world where this
is the kind of
joy they get to spread into the world
you're going to have to open your hands
and accept it and for the first time in
your life you're going to have to
understand that you're worth that that's
that's that type of support
you didn't get it from your family you
didn't get it from this loser that
you've been with for 15 years
and at some point you got to look in the
mirror and say behalf of my kids i've
got to understand that i got value
even if for a while you have to fake it
and pretend you have value
so you can teach your kids what value
looks like right
because they're looking to you and say
what does value look like
right and so sometimes it means dropping
your shoulders and saying i need help
and you need a lot less right you need a
lot
oh yeah and then i want you to find
somebody in your community that's going
to be a lawyer that's going to help you
go to war
and i tell you i know lawyers they live
for some these moments
oh these make them so happy they sit
there and work on
contracts and nonsense day after day
punching that six minute clock over and
over
and then a woman who's been beat down
and abused
and has five kids because her husband is
evil
and needs some help oh they start
licking their chops on this one
right those that support and that help
is there
it's going to start with you getting
really really clear about tiny
bite-sized chunks tiny bite-sized steps
you can take day after day after day
today i want you to call somebody that
will sit down and help you make a plan
for finding housing for your kids
i want you to stay on the line we're
going to get you these financial
resources these intentionality resources
and they have everything in this it's
got the budgeting stuff but it also has
where do i buy the cheapest fill in the
blank how do i
make a deal on this deal what happens
when my car goes out it's got a
step-by-step plan for all these
different processes
and will teach you how to get on a
budget teach you how to be intentional
right i want you to sit down with
somebody today and help them
help them help you make a plan for your
kids they gotta be under a roof they
gotta have showers you gotta have
plumbing
you can't be in a pop-up camper with
five children
i can't be with my well never mind
you're just a stud you're incredible and
you have value
you've got worth and i want you to know
you've got a whole country of people
rallied around you
we need to know what you need okay and
if you live in this
area mobile alabama i want you and
somebody comes knocking on your door
you're gonna open it you're gonna
welcome people in because that's what we
do that's where we're at as a country
we've got to start welcoming people in
and if you're listening to this and
you're an abusive person
and you lord over people with violence
you load over people with
fix my house you load over people with
rape and power today you're done
you're done enough
go with the help you need stop it's
generational
you're not that important stop
no actually you know what you are that
important
we need no more of it enough liz thank
you for being brave
call anytime you need something and
we'll be here the best we can help you
with
then i want you to put your church on
notice i want you to put your community
on notice that liz needs some support
and then you're gonna be about changing
this thing from the inside out and
you're gonna look up in five years and
ten years
and you will have a group of kids five
kids that are growing up
understanding their mom is a rock star
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel it's gonna be a long walk but
there's a light there and you can't
do it alone thank you so much for your
call liz as we wrap up today's show
let's see here what do we got
oh man
there's a little bit on the nose today
everybody but it's a really remarkable
song
um my buddy matt cass sent it to me last
night as a reminder i'd forgotten how
great this song is
it's off the search for everything
record it's
by john mayer and you know what i like
him i think he's good
i think john mayer is great he's the
best guitarist and songwriters working
today
he does play fenders though well played
james i see what you're doing there he
does play fender so i'll give him that
song's called in the blood off the
search for everything record and it goes
like this
how much of my mother has my mother left
in me and how much of my love will be
insane to some degree
and what about this feeling that i'm
never good enough will it wash out in
the water or is it always in the blood
and how much of my father am i destined
to become will i dim the lights inside
me just to satisfy someone
will i let this woman kill me or do away
with jealous love will it wash out in
the water or is it always
in the blood i can feel the love i want
i can feel the love i need
but it's never gonna come the way i
am could i change it if i wanted could i
rise above the flood will it wash out in
the water or is it always
in the blood ladies and gentlemen you
can you can rise above the flood
this is the dr john daloni show
you